all right who's ready to talk about the
superb
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah you all know what I'm talking
about it was the big football game had a
bunch of trailers show on it and yeah
I'm actually not gonna say what the name
of it is because I I don't know how bad
the NFL is about hunting down people on
things like YouTube but I do know they
are notorious trademark hounds with
anyone that they feel is proper you know
making some profit off the name of that
game so yeah just because I've had
enough of a headache with very spurious
copyright claims lately I'm just not
gonna risk it and so I'll just talk
about the trailers because there were a
fair number of them and in case I was
asking
no I didn't watch the game I actually
didn't find out who won and except by
proxy
Joe about I don't know almost 24 hours
later but any case let's talk about the
trailers cuz there were a fair number of
them and a fair number of them were
about the kinds of stuff that I like to
talk about I'm not gonna cover every
single trailer I think I am gonna cover
almost every trailer like I think you
know what I'm not gonna talk about is
the handmaiden season 3 trailer just cuz
I haven't gotten around to seeing that
show yet so as far as what is on there
um these are gonna be in no particular
order except that I am gonna save my
favorite trailer for the last thing that
I talked about but prior to that I'm
just gonna talk about them as I remember
them or as I you know check my notes if
I need to do that
so first up we had actually several mini
trailers for scary stories to tell in
the dark now this was something that I
like the name seemed vaguely familiar to
me and the trailers were were
interesting I I'm my assumption and I
didn't look more carefully into this I
could have I didn't is that this is
gonna be kind of an anthology horror
thing
which is presumably why they did the for
many trailers to help give that
impression as opposed to neo misleading
people into thinking it was like some
grander story when it's not it was also
interesting that it went back and forth
because out of these four many trailers
half of them mentioned here Modell Toro
who I think is producing this and half
mentioned that it was based off a hit
book and actually what I said that I did
stop and check that I think I actually
read some of these stories when I was in
grade school I'm pretty sure they were
in the school library I can't be sure
like I read more than a little bit of
sort of collections of McCobb stories
for younger readers when I was a kid
because I could why not
so I feel like I probably read some of
these I couldn't be certain though um
getting off that and actually talking
about the trailers they're quick they're
punchy they can get the job done
given that the book series is for
younger readers I'm gonna assume it's
probably gonna end up pg-13 pretty legit
for some of it though like the one that
got me did actually kind of get me go uh
is this girl's checking out like this
bump on her cheek and there's like it
looks like a hair sticking out black
hair and then like she looks and it
twitches and you realize it's like an
insect leg that may be ski because
that's a bit of a hot but like the idea
of stuff crawling under your skin huh
like ah it's not it's not like a it's
not like a gut-level like a phobia level
fear but oh god that creeps me out so I
mean pretty effective as far as that
goes it's I mean the whole ideas of this
movie is now on my radar way more than
it was before so I guess that that
counts as an accomplishment we had a
couple trailers from Marvel there was
Avengers endgame which you know we
didn't get much more plot for the stuff
we already knew about because well
you've only got 30 seconds so best to
convey mood rather than plot it was
interesting to contrast this with the
trailer that's already hit cuz the
trailer that hit was a bit more sort of
mournful a bit more you know in the wake
of disaster whereas this one felt
more defiant and a little bit more okay
we do not accept this and I liked that
feel and I think it was also a good
thing because I think hammering on the
melancholy of that first trailer which I
think was perfect for that first trailer
continuing to hammer on that trailer
after trailer would actually burn people
out and have everybody go like oh god
this is just gonna be depressing like no
we're fighting back now now if I was the
kind of person to go through frame by
frame and really parse out and think
what what can I my guess is gonna happen
in the in the movie based off these
image I probably could but I'm also just
not that guy it was a cool trailer I
liked it the Captain Marvel trailer this
annoyed me I actually think is the best
Captain Marvel trailer we've had so far
and it was 30 seconds long yeah that
kind of irritates me it just felt like
it had a much cleaner focus you know
with the with the recurring sort of
mantra you know about being better
faster stronger and and and all of that
and you know I like kind of the double
meaning that's involved in that because
it sort of first gets said by Carol
Danvers as a pilot and that makes sense
as a you know just being in the military
and striving to be the best at your job
that you can be to be better to be
faster to be stronger to just do that
but then to have that like sort of
filtering over to her role as a soldier
and the Kree Empire and the idea of
pushing her as a hero and yes if you
want to layer in the just the idea of
its a of you know pushing a woman
pushing to be those things because she
has to she has to rise to the occasion
because she's gonna be scrutinized more
you could add that layer to it as well
I'm sure the marketing people knew that
was in the mix but it was it was to the
point the images were solid to build on
the trailer was good I really liked it
and I've actually I like I know some
people have been too harsh on the
Captain Marvel trailers I've liked them
I liked this better than the Lions I
already liked which as I say kind of
annoys me because I'm like why couldn't
you come out with something this good of
this point what else was Oh Aleta had a
new trailer which looked fine I know I
le critical word on this thing is mixed
which makes me nervous I'm gonna say it
regardless cuz I've been waiting for
this movie since I was in college like
seriously that's when I found out James
Cameron had snagged the the rights to
make the movie and this was before he
started working on Avatar so I have been
waiting for this movie for a long time I
don't like I don't know if it's gonna
work but I'm gonna see it no matter what
and the trailer was fine
Oh Hobson Shaw alright ah confession
time I have yet to see a fast in the
Furious movie like any of them hide like
that's not like I'm jus rooted for these
movies but like when the series first
started I saw a woman like that looks
dumb and I have no interest now as
they've gotten more recent I have been
going that looks dumb and like I might
have an out an awful lot of fun with it
I just haven't actually gotten to I I
had wanted to see the 8th one in the
theatre because I figured why the heck
not I don't feel like I need deep lore
to get into the series but I I didn't
catch it and so here we are but I I do
like the feel and the vibe off this I
feel like we haven't had this kind of
antagonizing buddy you know action
comedy in a while it was really kind of
the bread and butter for Hollywood for
for a chunk of time there and it's
really kind of faded we get it
sporadically like now and then like I
would say the nice guys was kind of a
buddy you know action buddy cop kind of
thing but this like feels but that I
mean that was also a low budget that was
Shane black working basically
independent and whereas this is like
this has the kind of money thrown at it
that things like
Lethal Weapon 3 had thrown at it back in
the day so it's kind of I I kind of like
seeing something like this having that
much money thrown at it again and I like
the contrast between Dwayne Johnson and
Jason Statham I feel like they bounce
off each other well and the contrast is
good but like in a way that's like I
want to see these guys shares
yeah I whether or not I'll rush out to
see this I don't know yeah I mean like
really it depends on what I'm up to when
it's in the theater as to whether or not
I will carve out time for it not and if
I don't get to it it's not because I
decided I didn't want see it'll just be
because I had other stuff going on like
the the number of films that I'll
actually like I will force myself to
find time it's - isn't that high but I
hope I catch it and like said I had
hoped I would have caught the eighth
Fast and Furious and I missed that so
hopefully I won't miss this and we'll
see if it's finally my hook into this
franchise a couple of - ghost Toy Story
4 and fine
well I I've just I there's nothing about
the concept the pitch the title the
trails you had up to this point gives me
any enthusiasm you know I don't even
think Toy Story 3 is the best toy story
movie but it was the way to end it
wasn't ending it was definitively an
ending like I don't nothing that I'm
seeing makes me think it's worth it you
know to bring these characters back and
to remove the closure you know and you
can say well that was just the ending of
that story here's the start of another
one I'm like ok but the only way I'm
gonna swallow that is if you tell me a
really good news story and you know not
that I expected the super game trailer
to turn me around on something I was
already skeptical of but you know it's
just one more bit of marking that I'm
like yep still not convinced so let's
get to my my favorite trailer of this
whole thing The Twilight Zone trailer I
love everything about this thing I would
actually be really curious to know if
anyone was actually watching the game as
it aired did people think for like a hot
second that the that like the feed had
gone wonky before you realized it it was
a trailer I hope so because I like the
way that it was cut together and I feel
like it
the charade up like just long enough
where if they've done it any longer
people would have been genuinely ticked
off who they've done it any shorter it
wouldn't have like sunk in what might
have been happening and then you know
just that that empty field and Jordan
Peele walking up and that door and the
mutiny me me me me me now like there's I
think this is an absolutely perfect
trailer for now and not just in a vacuum
in context because the the notion of
reviving the twilight zone when I first
heard that they were gonna do that I'm
like really are you sure that's a good
idea because like look the twilight zone
was a seminal show insanely influential
both as a general concept and specific
stories that appeared in it incredibly
influential
and also very quickly copied I mean it
wasn't that much longer that the Outer
Limits came out and then you know all
sorts of things since then have ain't it
to one degree or another and these days
we are not lacking for horror ish sci-fi
ish you know kind of dark anthology
shows I mean we've got black marrow
we've got inside number nine I mean if
you it's not an anthology episode by
episode but we've got American Horror
Story you know what is it that the
Twilight Zone can bring to the table
that we don't already have well I think
there's one thing you can bring to the
table and it's the thing that they
missed it was the key ingredient that
they either missed or got wrong the last
two times they tried to revive this show
and that is the host because think back
on the Twilight Zone if you've actually
watched it a big part of the unique
field that was Rod Serling in trowing
and out rowing every episode that gave
it a very distinct flavor much more so
than the individual stories being told
were because a lot of the stories if you
looked at them in isolation without the
intro and outro they could have been
tires own could have been outer limits
but you put him back in it it is you
becomes uniquely Twilight Zone now when
they tried to revive this show in 85 I
don't think they even had a host at all
and then they tried to revive it in 2002
they had Forest Whitaker and I like
Forest Whitaker a lot that wasn't a good
fit though because Forest Whitaker you
know he's got his kind of a his slouchy
look and they had him dressed kind of
casually and he just he just looked like
a guy on the street what was great about
Rod Serling's intro and in that original
series was that you know he was buttoned
down he had his suit he had his tie he
sounded very authoritative he sounded
likes maybe someone who had properly
documented this and was going to educate
you about the thing you're about to see
and yet oftentimes he felt like he came
he felt out of place like we're in the
setting that all of a sudden there's a
student a suit where'd he come from
what's he doing there he simultaneously
felt like an authority on what you were
watching yet like he didn't belong there
and I feel like what we see of Jordan
Peele and this captures that perfectly
from the look to the demeanor to the
line delivery without ever sounding like
he's trying to do a Rod Serling
impression this feels genuine to Jordan
Peele yet exactly slots into what Rod
Serling was for that show and if they
can nail that and just not screw up the
stories it could be a truly worthy
revival because I do think that that is
the missing ingredient that caused the
previous revivals of The Twilight Zone
to just kind of come and go and when
people think the Twilight Zone they
never think 85 2002 maybe they will
think this new one we'll see that was a
great trailer so those are my thoughts
on sort of the little rush of trailers
we got associated with the big game
which happens every single year so what
were your thoughts on these trailers
were there any that I missed aside from
the handmade one any commercials you
like because I didn't go back and review
the commercials I just stuck to the
trailers all right you know whatever
your thoughts are about any of it
drop something out in the comments let's
talk about it a whole bunch of stuff to
do down there cuz there's buttons and
links errs once the patreon and that is
greatly appreciated I recently
restructured the patreon rewards so the
the tear to actually get your name in
the end credits coming up in a few
minutes is lower than it previously was
so maybe consider checking that out
but even if you don't want to there's
other links to look at and even if you
don't want to look at those that is okay
too
because at the end of the day folks you
are the council and I I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]